the way the game works is I'm just going
to Rifle off a quick word or phrase you
tell me the first word or phrase that
comes to mind I don't know if you
remember this game from last time yeah
then we're done all right the Only Rule
is that you can't repeat yourself twice
so think about like a word relation game
you're familiar with this uh first word
is Kobe Bryant
obsessed
the key to a successful marriage or
relationship
um
the work you do
18 months before getting married like
the due diligence you do before and
asking the questions before you get
married
you know how you get married you know
once you're married you're screwed
because you're in it so now you got to
really make it work but if you're not
married yet it's what you do before
getting married
that matters because that sets the
expectations up front the biggest lesson
you learned in Monaco when the deal
closed or most profound thought you had
in Monaco
I love Monaco
hello Monaco I love Central pay I love
everything about that area it's just
that every time I go there I'm so happy
I'm smiling like this every second when
I'm in Monaco it's the most billionaires
in the world live there right yeah it's
it's a beautiful it's smaller than
Central Park by the way that's how small
the place is
smaller than Central Park and you know
what's an interesting fact here's a
crazy fact for you do you know what's
the highest life expectancy expectancy
country in the world Monaco 89 and a
half people live good people live
yeah so yeah they they have great health
insurance they have everything but they
live a long life I love that yeah four
would be the biggest misconception you
had about you know big money you know
maybe that you know when when you're a
kid dreaming about like a nine figure
situation what's the biggest
misconception you have being on this
side of the fence
this misconception you know the the
concept of More Money More Problems so
some people are afraid that when you
have more money you have more problems
that is a misconception you don't have
more problems because you have smarter
brains around you that handle each of
those individual problems so it's not
More Money More Problems it's more money
more advisors
best advice you've ever been given in
business
this is a big man this is this changes
very often
uh
it's it's different at different phases
of life so it's different when I was 21
getting started versus 25 versus 29
about to start a company versus like
I'll give you one of them
before starting a company how about that
I'm 29 years old
the first person that knows that I'm
about to start a company one of the
first two people that knows it's the
spending bill so we meet in San
Bernardino at this breakfast joint like
a Denny's a slightly better quality food
and I sit down and I tell them I said
listen uh I know exactly what I want to
do I know what our cause is
this is our mission statement save in
America by bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to American
families I said to him I want to put an
event I want to dress like George
Washington I want my wife to dress like
Lady Liberty I want to have a 40-foot
Mount Rushmore on the stage I want to
bring Reagan's son to speak I want to
bring somebody from the Claremont
Institute I want to talk about the Star
Spangled Banner with Dudley Rutherford I
want to get everybody to realize we're
going on a big ass movement to make
everybody realize the American dream
starts with entrepreneurship not
homeownership that's what I want to do
he says that's your mission statement I
said yeah
he says I wouldn't launch it yet when
are you planning on telling people I
said this week he said don't do it I
said why not he said
if you launch a mission and a vision
this big
and your people don't see
you know because you're sitting up here
saying one day we're gonna have
presidents come to our events Senators
the number one comedian Kobe Bryant all
these guys because I did this video
dressed as doc from Back to the Future
and this is like 2010 and I said one day
presidents will come to the event one
day Kobe brown one day the best
comedians will come to the event he says
don't do it unless you're fully
committed to it because your people will
look at you as a phony so scared the
crap out of me
because it's a lot of pressure now right
because you have to come through so I'm
like oh I'm not starting it yet I'm not
telling people this yet
so I stepped away nobody knows I'm going
through this conversation with this man
and I walked away and I said yeah I'm
not ready yet
uh 90 days later I said I'm gonna do
part two breakfast with you we go back I
said I'm doing it
he said so you're committed to it I said
yes this is I want to be at the event
anyways so I did it I announced it and
then the moment I announced it and I
give everybody a shirt with all the
vision four things on it right
and I said we're going for it well
that night I've never slept with that
kind of anxiety and panic in my body as
that night because officially the world
knows what the vision is so it was one
of the best advice because before you go
out there and talk a big game about what
you're gonna do if it comes out of your
mouth that you don't come through
what you're really doing is everybody is
sitting out there saying he's just a
talker not a doer so I don't know if
that advice made any sense but not that
phase of my life very valuable advice
and the last one is what's the biggest
limiting belief you had to overcome
along your journey thus far
you know I'll tell you one of them
um
I said this is a big one okay I'll tell
you one of them one of them is uh
thinking everybody has that one two or
three people in your mind that man if I
don't get that person's blessing or
endorsement I'm never gonna make it it's
not true
you want me to unpack that or does that
kind of make sense you guys got the time
because I know we're tired on time here
but so here's what I mean by that when a
when a person when a person says you
know you're sitting there you're like
man that guy has to give me the blessing
but I gotta get his confirmation Mission
I gotta get not permission it's more
like you know uh if I don't interview
that guy if I don't get that carrier if
I don't get that investment from that
guy if I don't get that person to sit on
my board if I don't get that person as
an advisor if I don't get that person
um
you know we're not gonna it's not gonna
happen for us it's not true okay because
the way life works is in a following way
here's what I've learned
if
if you have a sincere vision
and you're constantly making progress
towards that Vision I don't know why
this is the case
the people you need for that up here if
it's real and if you're committed it's
such an interesting dynamic
you know for the longest time I would go
to New York and I would do six
interviews over two days so imagine like
you're preparing for one interview and
imagine doing three of them and three
two-hour interviews okay so boom boom
boom your brain is fried and then I'm
doing conference call at night for my
sales team and in the morning I'm going
on four hours of sleep and I gotta do
three more interviews the next day and
then I gotta go to another event to
speak to 600 people
so it's like you're going through this
like oh my God and I'm the booker people
are not coming to Dallas who goes to
Dallas to do interviews
so
versus the last two years or the last 18
months
the types of people that call like if I
told you who was here five days ago
spending five hours with me you wouldn't
believe it if I told you just five days
ago who was here who was it I mean you
wouldn't believe it if I told you but
you know who it is one of the most
powerful people in the world could get a
hand quickly yeah he lives in America
he's a very big hint I just gave you
right but uh the the point is now
they're reaching out
so that one person you thought you
needed is now calling you it's it's a
very
um
just go validate that you're a player in
the marketplace and those eight people
that you thought you needed
You're Gonna Want This I can't even
believe my I was my hanger hung up you
know I was hung up on that one guy or
another two no your kid Mark it's gonna
validate you I love that yeah all right
well thank you so much Pat I appreciate
that for you guys listening around the
world make sure to follow Pat in the
link in the description down below if
you guys don't already until next time
Live Strong live with passion and like
Pat mentioned make sure to go out and
live that Vision over the long term
we'll see you guys in the next inspiring
episode Peace
foreign
[Music]